de la crianza de los niños sin ninguna norma que nos guíe?
Bien, para empezar, ha habido un cambio histórico importante.
Hasta hace bastante poco, los chicos trabajaban,
en nuestras granjas principalmente, pero también en fábricas, molinos, minas.
Los niños eran considerados activos económicos.
En algún momento de la Era Progresista, pusimos fin a este acuerdo.
Reconocimos que los niños tenían derechos, prohibimos el trabajo infantil,
y en lugar de eso nos enfocamos en la educación y la escuela pasó a ser
el nuevo trabajo del niño.
Y gracias a Dios así fue.
Pero eso hizo el rol de los padres en cierta forma más confuso.
El viejo acuerdo puede no haber sido muy ético, pero era reciproco.
Proveíamos alimento, vestimenta, techo e instrucción moral a nuestros niños,
y ellos, a cambio, aportaban ingresos.
Cuando los niños dejaron de trabajar, la economía de la crianza cambió.
Los niños se convirtieron, en palabras de un brillante y despiadado sociólogo,
en algo "Sin valor económico, aunque emocionalmente inestimable".
En lugar de que ellos trabajaran para nosotros,
empezamos a trabajar para ellos, pues en solo cuestión de décadas
quedó claro que si queríamos que nuestros hijos triunfaran,
la escuela no bastaba.
Hoy, las actividades extracurriculares son el nuevo trabajo de los chicos,
pero también es un trabajo para nosotros, porque somos nosotros
quienes los llevamos a practicar fútbol.
Las montañas de tareas son el nuevo trabajo de un niño,
pero también son trabajo para nosotros, porque tenemos que revisarlas.
Hace unos tres años, una mujer de Texas me dijo algo
que rompió por completo mi corazón.
Me dijo, de una manera casi casual, "La tarea es la nueva cena".
La clase media dedica hoy en día todo su tiempo, energía y recursos a los hijos,
a pesar de que tiene cada vez menos de estas cosas para dar cada día.
Las mamás pasan hoy más tiempo con sus hijos que en 1975,
cuando la mayoría de las mujeres no eran aún parte de la fuerza de trabajo.
Probablemente sería más fácil cumplir con los nuevos roles,
si los papás supieran para que están preparando a sus hijos.
Esta es otra cosa que hace que la crianza moderna sea tan confusa.
No tenemos ni idea de qué parte de lo que sabemos les puede servir
a nuestros hijos, si es que hay algo.
El mundo está cambiando tan rápidamente que es imposible saberlo.
Esto era así inclusive cuando yo era joven.
Cuando era niña, más exactamente en la secundaria,
me decían que estaría perdida en la nueva economía global
si no sabía japonés.
Y con el debido respeto hacia los japoneses, no fue así.
Hoy día, hay un cierto tipo de padres clase media obsesionados
con enseñarle a sus hijos mandarín, y tal vez tengan razón,
pero no podemos asegurarlo.
Así que, siendo incapaces de anticipar el futuro,
lo que hacemos, como padres, es tratar de preparar a nuestros hijos
para cualquier clase posible de futuro, esperando que alguno de nuestros esfuerzos
dé en el blanco.
Les enseñamos a nuestros niños a jugar ajedrez, pensando que tal vez
necesiten capacidades de análisis.
Los inscribimos en equipos deportivos, pensando que tal vez necesiten
capacidades para el trabajo en equipo, ya saben, para cuando vayan
a la Escuela de Negocios de Harvard.
Les enseñamos a ser buenos en la economía,
a tener espíritu científico y a ser ecológicos y libres de gluten,
aunque tal vez sea hora de decirles que yo no era ecológica
ni libre de gluten cuando era niña.
Comía olladas de puré de macarrones y carne.
¿Y saben qué? Me está yendo bien.
Pago mis impuestos.
Tengo un trabajo estable.
Hasta me invitaron a hablar en TED.
(Risas)
Pero la presunción de ahora es que lo que era bueno para mí entonces,
ya no alcanza.
Y entonces todos nos abalanzamos sobre esa estantería de libros
porque creemos que si no lo intentamos todo, es como si no hiciéramos nada,
y como si faltáramos a nuestros deberes de padres.
Ya es bastante difícil cumplir con nuestros nuevos roles de padres y madres.
Agreguémosle a este problema algo más: también estamos asumiendo nuevos roles
de esposos y esposas, porque la mayoría de las mujeres,
hoy en día, forman parte de la fuerza laboral.
Esta es otra razón, creo, para que la crianza se viva como crisis.
No tenemos reglas, ni guiones, ni normas para lo que debemos hacer
cuando llega un niño, hoy que ambos, padre y madre, aportamos económicamente.
El escritor Michael Lewis, alguna vez, lo expresó con mucho acierto.
Dijo que la manera más segura de que una pareja empezara a pelear,
era que salieran a cenar con una pareja que tuviera un reparto de tareas
ligeramente diferente al suyo, pues la conversación en el auto
de regreso a casa, sería más o menos la siguiente:
"¿Te fijaste que Dave es el que lleva a los chicos a la escuela todos los días?"
(Risas)
Sin guiones que nos digan quién hace qué en este mundo feliz,
las parejas pelean y ambos, padre y madre,
tienen sus propias y legítimas quejas.
Las mamás son más dadas a ser multitarea cuando están en casa,
y los papás son más dados a ser monotarea.
Encuentren un tipo en casa, y lo más probable es
que esté haciendo solo una cosa a la vez.
De hecho, la Universidad de California recientemente hizo un estudio
para investigar la configuración más común de los miembros de familias clase media.
¿Adivinen qué se supo?
El papá en un cuarto solo.
Según la "Encuesta norteamericana del uso del tiempo",
las madres hacen el doble que los padres,
en cuanto al cuidado de los hijos, lo cual está mejor de lo que era
en los tiempos de Erma Bombeck, aunque todavía pienso
que algo de lo que escribió es absolutamente relevante:
"No he estado sola en el baño desde octubre".
(Risas)
Pero esta es la cuestión: los hombres están haciendo mucho.
Ellos pasan más tiempo con los hijos del que sus padres
nunca pasaron con ellos.
Trabajan más horas pagadas en promedio que sus esposas,
y quieren, genuinamente, ser padres buenos y comprometidos.
Hoy, son los padres, no las madres, los que informan la mayoría de los conflictos
entre el trabajo y sus vidas.
De cualquier manera, a propósito, si Uds. piensan que es difícil
para las familias tradicionales lidiar con estos nuevos roles,
solo imagínense cómo son ahora las cosas para las familias no tradicionales:
familias con dos padres, con dos madres, hogares con un solo padre.
Ellos en verdad están improvisando por el camino.
En países más progresistas, y discúlpenme por recurrir al cliché
e invocar, sí, a Suecia, los padres pueden recurrir al Estado
por ayuda.
Hay países que reconocen las angustias y los cambios de roles de padres y madres.
Desafortunadamente, los EE. UU. no es uno de ellos,
así que si se estaban preguntando qué tienen los EE. UU. en común
con Papúa Nueva Guinea y Liberia, es esto:
Nosotros tampoco tenemos política de licencia de maternidad pagada.
Somos uno de los 8 países del mundo que no la tienen.
En esta época de confusión intensa, hay solo una meta
con la cual todos los padres concuerdan, y es que así se sea
mamá tigre o hippie, helicóptero o drone,
la felicidad de nuestros hijos es primordial.
Eso es lo que significa educar a los hijos en una época en la que no tienen
valor económico, pero son emocionalmente invaluables.
Todos somos custodios de su autoestima.
El único mantra que ningún padre cuestiona es:
"Todo lo que quiero es que mis hijos sean felices".
Y no me entiendan mal: creo que la felicidad
es una maravillosa meta para cualquier niño.
Pero es una meta demasiado escurridiza.
La felicidad y la autoconfianza, enseñarle eso a los niños
no es como enseñarles a arar un campo.
No es como enseñarles a andar en bici.
No hay un currículo para eso.
La felicidad y la autoconfianza pueden ser productos derivados de otras cosas,
pero no pueden ser metas en sí mismas.
Es muy injusto cargar sobre los hombros de los padres
la felicidad de sus hijos.
Y es todavía más injusto cargar la felicidad sobre los hombros de los niños.
Y tengo que decirles que creo que conduce a algunos excesos muy extraños.
Estamos hoy tan ansiosos por proteger a nuestros hijos
de la hostilidad del mundo, que los protegemos de "Plaza Sésamo".
Quisiera poder decir que es un chiste, pero si van a comprar el DVD
de los primeros episodios de "Plaza Sésamo", como hice yo por nostalgia,
se encontrarán con una advertencia al comienzo
que dice que el contenido no es apropiado para niños.
(Risas)
¿Puedo repetirlo?
El contenido del "Plaza Sésamo" original no es apropiado para niños.
Cuando el New York Times le preguntó por esto
a una productora del show, dio un sinnúmero de explicaciones.
Una fue que el Monstruo Galletero fumaba pipa en una escena
y luego se la tragaba.
Mal ejemplo. ¡Supongo!
Pero lo que más se me grabó fue cuando dijo que no sabía
si Oscar El Gruñón podría utilizarse hoy, porque era demasiado depresivo.
No puedo decirles cuánto me aflige todo esto.
(Risas)
Están viendo a una mujer que tiene una tabla periódica
de los Muppets colgando de la pared de su cubículo.
El ofensivo muppet, justo ahí.
Ese es mi hijo el día que nació.
Yo volaba como cometa por la morfina.
Me habían hecho una cesárea inesperada.
Pero incluso en mi nube de opio, me las arreglé para tener una idea clara
la primera vez que lo alcé.
Se lo susurré al oído. Le dije:
"Intentaré por todos los medios no herirte".
Fue un juramento hipocrático, y no sabía que lo era.
Pero se me ocurre ahora que el juramento hipocrático
es una meta mucho más realista que la felicidad.
De hecho, como puede decírselos cualquier padre,
es una meta dificilísima.
Todos hemos hecho o dicho cosas hirientes
de las que desearíamos con todo el alma poder retractarnos.
Creo que en otra época, no hubiéramos esperado tanto
de nosotros mismos y es importante que todos lo recordemos
la próxima vez que estemos mirando con nuestro corazón agitado
esas estanterías de libros.
No sé exactamente cómo crear normas nuevas para este mundo,
pero sí creo que en nuestro desesperado afán
por hacer niños felices, podemos estar asumiendo
cargas morales equivocadas.
Me convence más, como una mejor meta, y una más virtuosa, me atrevo a decir,
que nos concentremos en lograr niños productivos y niños morales,
y que esperemos que sencillamente la felicidad les llegue
en virtud del bien que hagan, de sus logros
y del amor que reciban de nosotros.
Eso, de alguna forma, es una respuesta al hecho de no tener un guion.
Como no tenemos guiones nuevos, solo sigamos los más viejos del libro
—decencia, trabajo ético, amor— y dejamos que para la felicidad y la autoestima
se las arreglen por sí mismas.
Creo que si todos hiciéramos eso, los chicos estarían muy bien,
al igual que sus padres, y posiblemente en ambos casos,
incluso mejor.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)